north las vegas police piecing together
what led to a deadly turn of events at a
fourth of july celebration
nine people were shot two are dead this
happened on helen avenue near kerry and
martin luther king boulevard kate
houston speaking with neighbors who say
fireworks were sold out they couldn't
hear the gunshots
we've had shootings drive-bys you know
but this is probably the worst i've seen
strands of caution
tape hang on fences along helen avenue
where the shooting happened
it's always concerning when you hear
something like that in any any
neighborhood
north las vegas police say they
responded to the call just after 11.
next you know i looked out down the
street and there was probably 15
20 cop cars i saw a homicide
investigation van
so i i knew something that happened
pretty bad
neighbors say there were multiple
parties going on for hours before the
shooting happened
me and my daughter we got out the car
and we seen people running so we
ran back around here and hopped back in
the van and went back home
north las vegas police say seven people
were injured and two men believed to be
in their early 20s
died nicholas powell and lila hampton
say this is a tight community
and worrisome for the parents i'm scared
for mine because i have two boys in
their 20s so
i'm kind of scared for that that's scary
monday afternoon detectives were
canvassing the block which was filled
with used fireworks and party cups
they're looking into all leads powell
who's lived in the neighborhood for
more than 15 years says the escalation
of violence in the area
is getting too close to home is it going
to come back and
you know maybe i'll have bullets flying
through my home
kate houston 8 news now